Buongiorno a tutti
come sappiamo un discorso Ted deve
portare All'attenzione del pubblico
nuove idee spunti originali il racconto
di una scoperta sensazionale
pensando però al mio intervento su
questo tappeto rosso mi sono reso conto
Tra le tante idee o forse più nel vuoto
dentro di me di non aver niente da dire
lo confesso Effettivamente non so perché
sono qui non so di cosa parlarvi non ho
niente di interessante Niente di nuovo
da aggiungere al mare di informazioni
che ci circonda ogni giorno
eppure non posso fare a meno di pensare
a come la nostra società ci spiega
costantemente ad avere qualcosa da dire
essere sempre pronti a parlare a postare
o a commentare
tutti devono avere un'opinione su ogni
cosa su ogni argomento
spesso le persone che parlano molto non
sempre sono quelle che sanno di più
Io credo che in questo momento in cui
tutti sembrano voler parlare a tutti i
costi sia più importante che a me saper
ascoltare
il rumore del motore mentre percorriamo
la strada
ascoltare il vento che ci accarezza il
viso oppure ascoltare il silenzio
il silenzio che ci circonda quando la
mente sembra essersi fermata
perché il silenzio può essere un dono
può darci la possibilità di riflettere e
di capire il senso di tutto
per me che sono un ragazzo timido
riservato e semplice questa cosa è Manna
il silenzio può essere un luogo di
riflessione Ma anche di solitudine La
solitudine di non avere qualcosa di
importante da dire di non avere una voce
che ci rappresenta e che ci fa sentire
parte di qualcosa di più grande
una solitudine che ci porta a sentirsi
inutili vuoti e che ci spinge
costantemente a cercare un senso o una
ragione per continuare a vivere
quando non è niente da dire puoi
semplicemente stare lì in silenzio e
osservare
osservare gli altri osservare il mondo
intorno a te e osservare te stesso
Se ci pensate bene Ogni grande scoperta
o realizzazione è nata dall'osservazione
attenta del mondo intorno a noi
il grande filosofo Rousseau diceva che
il silenzio è il vero amico che mai
tradisce
L'amicizia è secondo me proprio il luogo
dove il silenzio diventa un'opportunità
e quando siamo con le persone che amiamo
davvero che possiamo permetterci di
essere noi stessi senza filtri e senza
la paura di essere giudicati
molto spesso questo non è veritiero
almeno che non si tratti di un'amicizia
vera e profonda questo valore per me lo
si può avere con circa 5 10 15 persone
al massimo
Eppure io come credo anche voi di amici
ne ho tantissimi
definirli solo più che una semplice
conoscenza Ovviamente non è corretto ma
il valore che hanno rispetto a quelle 5
10 15 persone a noi più care per me è
completamente differente
L'amicizia è una delle relazioni più
belle e importanti che possiamo avere
nella vita è una connessione profonda
che va al di là delle semplici
conoscenze o relazioni di lavoro
questa relazione l'amicizia per me è
come credo per alcuni di voi ha avuto
inizio col percorso scolastico
crescendo con il passare del tempo
l'ambiente scolastico mi ha portato i
migliori amici che ho tuttora Alcuni di
loro sono qui ora che mi stanno
ascoltando
l'amicizia ci offre supporto compagnia e
conforto i momenti di gioia e di
difficoltà
ma a volte l'amicizia non ha bisogno di
parole per essere vera e significativa
il silenzio può essere molto importante
quando si condivide
o quando si prova una certa tristezza un
certo dolore invece di dire parole che
potrebbero risultare banali l'essere
semplicemente presenti in silenzio può
dare un conforto Maggiore alla persona
che sta soffrendo
facendole capire così che non è sola
il silenzio può essere molto importante
anche quando si chiude si condivide un
momento di felicità non sempre è
necessario parlare per condividere la
gioia con un amico
Tuttavia è importante ricordare che il
silenzio non deve essere l'unica forma
di comunicazione nell'amicizia la
comunicazione verbale è ovviamente
importante per stabilire una relazione
forte e duratura
perché dovremmo avere paura di esprimere
i nostri pensieri le nostre emozioni o i
nostri sentimenti anche quando sono di
difficili da affrontare
Il silenzio è un'esperienza
sottovalutata nella nostra società dove
siamo costantemente bombardati da un
mare di informazioni e rumori
ora vi chiedo gentilmente di chiudere i
vostri occhi per un momento fin quando
non vi dirò di riaprirli
Esiste un fenomeno noto come riscatto
sensoriale il quale si verifica quando
una persona perde l'uso di uno dei sensi
come la vista
il cervello di conseguenza intensifica
l'uso di un altro senso come l'udito Per
compensare la mancanza
questo processo può portare a un
miglioramento delle capacità uditive
poiché il cervello sviluppa nuove
connessioni neuronali per elaborare e
interpretare meglio i suoni
sentite il vostro respiro
il vostro vicino
avete sentito i miei passi
forse spostare la nostra attenzione
dall'immagine e dall'apparenza potrebbe
cambiare le cose
potrebbe azzardo cambiare il mondo
potete riaprirli Grazie
spesso ciò che è veramente conta è ciò
che non viene Detto ciò che si trova tra
le righe
accetto la tua vulnerabilità e cerca di
imparare qualcosa di nuovo da chi ti sta
ascoltando
Forse è proprio questa la lezione che io
sto prendendo in questo momento non
avere paura di essere insicuri di non
sapere tutto Perché solo così possiamo
imparare e crescere
E allora amici miei oggi vi chiedo di
accogliere la mia vulnerabilità e di
aiutarmi a scoprire qualcosa di nuovo
insieme
Alla fine forse scopriremo che non serve
avere sempre qualcosa da dire qualcosa
di interessante ma basta semplicemente
essere presenti aperti e pronti a
imparare dagli altri
chi lo sa Magari la nostra assenza di
parole Puoi respirare qualcun altro a
parlare
magari proprio il nostro silenzio può
essere la scintilla che accende un
dialogo più profondo e significativo
Grazie
[Applauso]